con el nuevo marco legal ningún
presidente ruso podrá eternizarse en el
cargo salvo vladimir putin el presidente
ruso ha firmado la ley que le permite
optar a dos nuevos mandatos si así lo
desea vladimir punto y llegó a la
presidencia rusa en el año 2000 lleva 21
años al frente del país la mayor parte
de ellos como presidente salvo un breve
periodo como primer ministro entre los
años 2008 y 2012 la nueva norma legal
impide que un presidente pueda hacerlo
durante más de dos mandatos incluso
aunque no sean consecutivos pero en el
texto de la nueva ley también se
establece que esta norma no se aplica a
la persona que sea presidente en el
momento de entrar en vigor la ley así
culmina un proceso que empezó el año
pasado con una reforma express de la
constitución que fue respaldada
mayoritariamente por los rusos